so i decided to put two of my cars
at an auction okay i have two of my uh
cars i was approached by heritage
auctions and they put my two cards on
heritage
this is one of them the wayne gretzky
psa 10 his rookie card 1979
the minimum reserve if you want to bid
for this right now it's 575
000 it would end up costing you 690
that's the next bid there's still
21 days left on this the minimum reserve
on this if you go lower to buy this card
go lower lower lower
lower it's a million dollars the reserve
is at a million dollars and people want
that card there's only two of them in
the car that's the holy grail
of the hockey card world i have no clue
what it's going to sell for
but we will know by december 14. the
next one is a tops card there's only two
of these
the next bid right the current bid is to
uh 210 the next bit is 220
with the 20 feet that heritage offer
charges you would be 264.
the two cards holy grail of hockey cards
on the market right you set the price
because they're yours they call me they
came and approached me a lot of guys
wanted this had a call with uh bruce
mcnally's ball wayne gretzky you know
the guy
they want honest wagner together him and
he was a former owner the kings himself
and uh i started getting a lot of weird
calls and i bought this couple years ago
i sent tikrun to go pick it up and they
went to psa headquarters
and they got the card uh uh in a brand
new case and
the guy needed cash and i said no
problem wired them uh
some money and we got the cards and i
didn't know what was going to happen
with it i was going to hang on to it
but then heritage came up to us the
owners they came we had a meeting here
they said let us
take the card and see what we can do
with it we'll offer a minimum at a
million
and 400 000 and you know we'll see
what's going to happen with this at this
point
um people are starting to realize how
much money there are
in collectibles you know a a matt
a mike trout card just sold for what 3.9
million dollars uh i spoke to the three
owners who owned the mickey mantle if
you go to 1952 tops
uh type in 1952 tops in search go to
google and type it make it don't don't
leave this side
yeah 1952 tops mickey mantle
ps there you go psa 10 go down there's
only three of them in the world
uh one of them doesn't want to sell the
other one is open to it and the third
one is asking me for 18 million dollars
to buy this card
uh click on images and we are actually
talking right now to see if that's
something i'm willing to do and i'm
definitely not going to go to 18 million
but uh
psa 10 right click on the first one
right here right there no no right here
right below it right below forbes right
there click on that
that's the card that is a that was uh
sold
two years ago for 12 million dollars um
that's an older price that they have on
there but it sold two years ago espn
reported 12 million dollars
that is today probably a anywhere
between 12 to 18 million auto card
1952 is that a real autograph or is that
just no that's not
that's that's the card that's like the
holy grail of cards
the mickey mantle that is the number
this is this has done laps over a
hundred swagger because honest wagner
they found that that it was cut with
scissors on why the quality was so good
they said the perfect one was cut with
scissors so that's right now probably
still worth 4 million
what's that worth that's probably a 15
million dollar card you're looking at so
you just buy that with
you buy this card for 15 million bucks
and you hang on to it for 20 years
you'll probably sell it for 50 million
bucks in 20 years
so you'll make 35 million in 20 years
you may make that money better in other
places but it's
like if you appreciate cards holding on
to that card is like
man it's like katherine zitter jones in
that movie going and stealing the most
expensive diamond in the world do you
remember that one movie what was this
movie with sean connery sean connor
she's going through the whole thing and
showing her body with the red the hell
was that movie i don't know what was it
called that movie
that's what this is this is the holy
grail so heritage asked me if you want
to go back to it if you have any
interest you can go to heritage auctions
type in wayne gretzky and if you want to
make an offer to add this to your
collectible this is probably going to be
a 10 15 20 million dollar card
in the next 10 or 20 years so that's
what we have there with that